[موسيقى] في
كل مرة عدت فيها إلى
موسكو ، لا يهم أن يكون
الجو مشمسًا جميلًا ، الطقس شديد البرودة ،
إنه المطر والثلج ، أنا سعيد للغاية
لأنني أحب العمل
[موسيقى]
موسكو هي مكان  الطاقة يمكن أن تكون
جميلة ويمكن أن تكون قبيحة
موسكو ، هذا أمر لا يصدق مع حركات
الجميع يركض هنا الجميع يدير
[موسيقى]
يطلق عليه تجاوز حتى الآن ولن يكون
رانشو
[موسيقى
] وهو شيء رائع لأن هناك بعض
الأشخاص المختلفين
أماكن معمارية مختلفة
[  موسيقى
] ولدت ونمت في موسكو ، أسست
متحف القلب متعدد الوسائط
حياتي ومتحف جراناتا الكبير ، إنه
متحف ذو مغزى ، لكن عندما أكون
مرهقًا
، أذهب إلى دير roblox عندما
أحتاج إلى لحظة صمت فهو
مكاني  الطاقة كل يوم أضعها هناك كلما
كان الطفل لأن جدتي أخذني
إلى هناك للعب في المدينة الكبيرة كانت
مشكلة حقيقية ، لذلك حدثت أشياء كثيرة ،
موسكو مليئة بالأماكن التي تتحول فيها الحياة
في مسيرتنا ،
انفجرت Grandal للثقافة ولا أعرف أبدًا ما الذي
سأراه هناك غدًا